well at least 20 people are missing in
japan after a landslide near tokyo take
a look at this video homes have been
swept away in the city of aktami
it's just southwest of the capital
torrential rain has been soaking the
area
for several days let's get an update and
bring in michael penn he's the president
of the shingetsu news agency joining us
from
tokyo thanks for speaking to us i mean
the pictures are
pretty astounding very scary just talk
us
through the scale of the destruction
that's been caused and
what you're hearing
okay well uh you know the pictures
actually very very much do
tell the story it is just that one area
where these landslides have occurred
there have been other
problems caused by the heavy rain but
not on that scale
somewhere higher up on that mountain
which is basically a coastal area
of a resort town tommy's very much kind
of a resort town
area uh began the the the gravel was
was made loose by a long period of heavy
rain
and this mudslide and debris uh
just clattered down the mountain and
started taking houses with it
and uh you know according to the
authorities
uh about 19 or 20 people are are thought
to be missing at this point
and you know really it was
a fearsome moment there for those in the
neighborhood and the authorities are
warning people to
look out for more because the rain
hasn't entirely stopped and this is
rainy season in japan
yeah and authorities are also warning
that the rain will continue over the
next few days so not very good news for
people who live there but
on the 19 or 20 people as you mentioned
that are missing
are you hearing anything about their
fate and authorities
do authorities expect that number to
rise
uh well uh it's not exactly clear at
this point uh
you know from experience and very
similar
uh sort of natural disasters uh it
usually takes actually a couple of days
before the exact number is known
because the japanese authorities tend to
be very
meticulous about making sure that what
they report to the media
is as accurate as possible so
what i would expect is that uh you know
these 19 or 20 people or so
uh will probably be listed as missing
for some time
until their bodies are begin to pull out
and then one by one that the number of
uh confirmed deaths will probably rise
to something like
the number of missing and the prime
minister we know has called for an
emergency meeting so we'll wait to see
what comes out of that but we also know
that the local government is now
requesting military assistance for a
rescue mission i mean how significant is
it that the military has to be called in
well actually in japan that's not so
unusual in the case of natural disasters
i mean as you probably know
japan is very much a natural disaster
country i mean there may be no country
on earth
that has as many uh natural disasters
and small areas as japan does
you know volcanoes earthquakes
landslides floods it's
it's it gets hit very heavy and so the
self-defense forces one of their
missions is to uh to go to these
disaster zones
and to kind of uh add some manpower to a
situation
where you know otherwise local
authorities might be overwhelmed
okay great thank you so much for
breaking that down for us michael penn
we appreciate your time from tokyo
thank you